So in a typical TCP three-way handshake, the
client sends a SYN packet to the server,
the server responds with the SYN-ACK, and the
client then returns with an ACK to the
SYN-ACK, at which point the connection is established.
The problem in a typical TCP three-way handshake
is that. The client can send a SYN and cause the server to allocate a socket
buffer for that TCP connection. But then if
the client never returns, the client can force
the server to allocate many, many socket buffers,
simply by sending a lot of syns and never
returning. In fact, these could even be from
spoofed IP addresses. So in other words, the client
has absolutely no accountability, and no obligation to
return to send the final ack, and yet can
cause the server to allocate resources. This is a problem, and the solution to
this is called syn cookies. In the
TCP syn cookie approach, when the server receives
a syn from the client, the server, instead of allocating a socket buffer for the
tuple associated with the connection. The server
keeps no state, and instead picks an initial
sequence number for the connection that's a function of the client's IP address,
and port, and the servers IP address, and port, as well as a random knots to
prevent replay attacks. An honest client that
returns can then reply with an acknowledgement
with that sequence number in the packet.
The server can check that sequence number simply
by rehashing all of the information that
it already has. Thereby determining that the
acknowledgement here corresponded to the previous SYN-ACK
that it had sent the client without
requiring the server to store any state. Only if the sequence number matches the
one picked by the server in the
syn-ack does the server actually establish the connection.